as an actor having someone who looks
exactly like you can give you a big
advantage while some duos like the olsen
twins or dylan and cole sprouse have
made it a part of their brand here are
some stars that you may not have
realized have an identical twin
in 2009 jill hennessy spoke with contact
music about the burdens her identical
twin jacqueline often faces saying she
gets stalked by people who don't believe
she's my twin she'll very kindly say i'm
jack her sister and they'll think she's
lying they think it's really jill
hennessy just being really
while jacqueline and her sister jill
have each carved out separate
accomplished careers on their own the
former has a phd in french literature is
a journalist and tv host and the latter
was claire kincaid on law and order and
the titular character on crossing jordan
the sisters have collaborated several
times in film and music they once had a
duo called jack and jill were buskers in
toronto's subways and still sing
together to this day the pair made their
film debut together playing twin escorts
and david cronenberg's 1988 drama dead
ringers in the 1996 land order episode
corpus delicti jacqueline literally
stood in for her sister for courtroom
scenes while jill was off shooting a
crossover episode with homicide life on
the street when jill wrote and directed
2000's the acting class she was sure to
include her older sister in the roll
call
while rami malek hit the big time as
elliott on tv's mr robot and as freddie
mercury in the biopic bohemian rhapsody
his identical twin brother sammy has
been spending his time handing out
grades as a teacher in los angeles sami
currently teaches english as a second
language at a middle school the only
time sammy gets into character and
costume is to protest and demand changes
for schools he's very passionate about
his vocation and is known to fight for
both teachers and students alike the
closest sammy gets to the limelight is
to celebrate his brother's success
particularly at the 2019 academy awards
when rami took home the best actor award
saying in a red carpet interview my boy
had it in the bag he killed it
rami has also joked that his success in
film and tv is likely to give his
brother a boost in his romantic life
during an appearance on jimmy kimmel
live rami told a switcheroo story where
he came to sami's aid when he needed to
do a greek monologue for a class in
order to graduate from ucla when sammy's
teacher was floored by the performance
rami responded um it's just a hobby
the first transgender person to be
nominated for an emmy laverne cox got
her breakout role as sophia bursette a
charismatic inmate in orange is the new
black when it came time to film
flashback scenes featuring sophia before
her transition however it was easy to
find the perfect fit laverne's twin
brother going by the name m lamar the
avant-garde artist is an operatic
countertenor and pianist whose music is
frequently blended with film sculpture
installation and performance the twins
had a difficult time growing up and
being different in their hometown of
mobile alabama they were constantly
bullied at school but their mother
gloria impressed upon them the
importance of education telling the
local paper in 2019 that she quote
groomed them for success while laverne
is out and proud lamar takes a more
subdued approach as he told world of
wonder in 2016 what i do is not designed
to cross over to the mainstream that's
not my goal i'm not looking for that
sort of fame or recognition however
lamar did indeed step into the
mainstream on one occasion when he
played the pre-transition version of
sophia bersett in the season one orange
is the new black episode lesbian request
denied cox originally wanted to play the
role herself but she told the huffington
post in 2013 that the episode's director
jody foster quote didn't think she
looked masculine enough to play a guy
harriet norton told the louisville
courier journal in 1971 about her famous
sister we used to say we'd both be in
the theater me on broadway and her in
the operating theater but she's the one
who got into show business norton's twin
sister was none other than ann b davis
known for playing the lovable and ever
dependable housekeeper alice on the
brady bunch and found early success on
the bob cummings show in the role of
schultzy which won her back-to-back emmy
awards in 1958 and 1959. after the
second win harriet wired her sister the
message one of us was bound to have
twins harriet was given the chance to
join anne in a schultzy double episode
but couldn't handle the lines so the
idea was scrapped this probably explains
why harriet wasn't enlisted to play
alice's identical cousin sergeant emma
on the brady bunch episode of the same
name where anne ended up taking on both
roles herself regardless the two
maintained an unwavering bond throughout
their entire lives and died in 2014 at
age 88. she never married and is
survived by harriet who currently
resides in tucson arizona
bonner bain never missed a chance to
take a playful swipe at his more famous
brother conrad bane of tv's mod and
different strokes telling the ottawa
citizen he's 20 minutes older than i am
and he looks every minute of it the two
bane boys were dedicated to their local
dramatic arts program and their teen
years trading off lead roles in their
school plays one conrad headed to new
york to advance his acting career bonner
chose a different more stable path back
in edmonton developing a successful
career in the airline rental car and
parking businesses however that didn't
stop him from taking an occasional part
when the writers of mod drummed up an
episode involving the escaped convict
twin of conrad's character arthur conrad
lamented i knew we were in trouble the
scriptwriters had my brother as a sex
maniac in the end conrad played both
parts and bonner quote only came in for
two lines at the end when he got caught
but everybody thought it was him the
whole time a similar experience took
place on the van drummonds episode of
strokes conrad played their dutch cousin
anna von drummond and in the scenes
where philip appeared alongside her
bonner acted as a stand-in bonner went
solo a few other times most memorably
spoofing conrad as alien double agent
hank bain on sctv appearing in a sketch
called different folks back in the 1940s
conrad was set to be an extra in a
canadian war propaganda film but got
sick right before the shoot bonner
stepped in for his brother and
remembered the casting director took one
look at me and said what difference does
it make bonner passed away in 2005 at
age 82 conrad followed in 2013 at age
89.
before linda hamilton was trying to
escape from the terminator she was
performing in community children's
theater back in salisbury maryland
alongside her sister leslie who was born
six minutes after she was linda recalled
in 1987 we would be cast in the same
role and work alternate performances it
was a real gimmick while linda made the
jump to hollywood leslie followed her
own passion by becoming a nurse and
caretaker leslie does have one credit to
her name however and it's in one of the
greatest action films of all time she
played a cyborg imitation of sarah
connor in terminator 2 judgement day and
was paid a thousand dollars for her time
and effort being on set not only gave
leslie a glimpse of the hollywood
limelight but also a taste of the fun
too as she once even convinced arnold
schwarzenegger himself into thinking she
was linda one film was more than enough
for leslie however after vowing to never
return to the franchise linda changed
her tune and suited back up as sarah
connor in 2019's terminator dark fate
leslie passed away in 2020 at age 63.
when the writers four days of our lives
asked their star deidre hall if there
were any story lines she'd like to
pursue she was quick to pitch the idea
of giving her character dr marlena evans
a twin sister not long after deidra's
sister andrea took a break from her
summer job as a special education
teacher to play marlena's jealous twin
samantha the job spilled beyond the
summer and ended up lasting several
seasons the first time the pair acted
together was in 1977 in the croft
brothers cult classic show elektra woman
and dyna girl where andrea played
deidra's clone andrea returned to days
of our lives in 2000 when she showed up
as hattie adams a woman who just so
happens to look exactly like marlena the
pandemic turned into a mixed blessing
for the twins who got to spend over nine
weeks together for the first time since
their youth andrea gushed it's like
finding your best friend again it's been
grand painting is so much fun but we
just mostly laughed
in 2007 john peter told elle magazine
that his relationship with twin daniel
is like a marriage my brother and i
think alike know everything about one
another and when we get together we
block everything else out nothing exists
in our world except for us the heater
boys were always artistic and followed
their brother doug to byu to study
animation jon found everlasting fame
playing the title role in 2004's
napoleon dynamite then went on to star
in such films as blades of glory and the
bench warmers daniel is a visual effects
artist who has worked on blockbuster
films like elita battle angel and
guardians of the galaxy he also worked
as an animator on 2006's monster house
where his brother john provided a
voiceover the two have acted together in
a few short films and ashton kutcher
helped daniel prank john in a 2005
episode of punk'd along with their older
brother doug they formed greasy
entertainment and have several projects
in the works including of course some
animated ones as for being twins outside
of work john has admitted that they
switched classrooms for a day in sixth
grade but the scheme backfired when
daniel took a pop quiz he obviously
wasn't prepared for
john heater wasn't the only twin to star
in napoleon dynamite as efrain ramirez
got a vote of confidence as the titular
hero's best friend pedro ephron and his
identical twin carlos were discovered on
the street by robert blake who got them
roles in the series hell town carlos
took a break from acting in 1991 and
joined the united states air force but
when ephron's career skyrocketed he
returned to the craft the two appeared
together in potheads the movie as well
as the high octane action movie crank
and its sequel crank high voltage they
shared screen time and many good times
in real life throwing famously raucous
dual birthday bashes unfortunately the
story of the ramirez brothers doesn't
have the happiest of endings the ramirez
twins had a falling out over carlos
making public appearances as efran
without his brother's consent according
to a 2013 tmz report efrain threatened
to sue his brother for 10 million
dollars in 2008 and they hadn't spoken
since carlos told tmz at the time i
think it's safe to say the magnitude of
napoleon dynamite and everything that
has come along with it has ruined my
relationship with my twin
as of present day both ramirez brothers
are still making appearances in films
and tv series just not together
if you've ever wondered what it's like
to have a celebrity doppelganger who's
starring in one of the most successful
shows of the 1990s firefighter caroline
paul detailed exactly how it feels and
her 2015 book almost heard the strange
dilemma of being nearly famous the
possibility of an identical twin never
crossed anyone's mind it was easier to
believe that the baywatch star had
decided to swaddle herself in a turnout
coat and helmet grab that axe and jump
on a fire engine for the day
caroline's slightly older twin sister is
actress alexandra paul who made a splash
on tv as stephanie holden for five
seasons of baywatch she's also made
appearances in films like christine 8
million ways to die and dragnet caroline
never joined the acting business herself
but did work on christine as alexandra
standin on set confusing director john
carpenter in the process alexandra told
the ohio news journal in 1999 how deep
her bond runs with caroline i'll always
have her even if everything else goes
badly it's like having your left arm or
something she means everything to me
despite what you might think on first
look sidra smith has something to say i
am not the lady from the tyler berry
movie
it's an easy mistake to make her
identical twin sister tasha is indeed
the lady from the tyler perry movie
having starred in 2007's why did i get
married and it's 2010 sequel in a 2017
instagram post sidra teased i'm the
oldest twin i always say that i came out
first because she kicked me out so she
could be in our mother's belly alone for
two minutes the sisters overcame a tough
upbringing and both left their hometown
of camden new jersey for greener
pastures while tasha made appearances in
films like couples retreat and shows
like empire sidra became a casting
director despite their difference in
occupation the two always strive to help
each other in their endeavors with tasha
telling npr in 2008 my sister is my
business partner my twin she's an
amazing producer writer you know we're
just grinding and trying to make my
mother proud as well as god the two did
appear on screen together once getting
the opportunity to say a single word
between the two of them in the film twin
sitters while they have confused many
fans in public they also have fooled the
technology of apple proving that
identical twins can pass for the other
when using iphone's face activation
security feature
nicholas brendan had dreams of playing
for the dodgers but an injury took him
off the baseball diamond and onto a tv
set nicholas found early success as
xander harris in buffy the vampire
slayer while his brother kelly took
industry jobs behind the scenes as a set
decorator when kelly finally decided to
join his brother in the limelight he
landed a role on buffy as a xander
double in the season 5 episode the
replacement the pair also appeared
together for several episodes of
hollywood squares and the mind-bending
2013 horror film coherence despite
kelly's later start nicholas has always
been happy to boost his brother in any
way he can in 1999 nicholas told teen
people that the duel have a very special
relationship saying there's this
unexplained twin phenomenon that even we
can't understand the two have so much in
common in fact that they've been known
to spontaneously belt out the same song
at the exact same time and have even had
similar recurring dreams
actress lorraine velez is very close
with her slightly younger sister but not
too close she once told latin heat my
sister is part of my journey but not all
of it i exist as an individual
lorraine's twin sister luna lauren velez
is also an actress singer and dancer the
vella's twins both attended the alvin
ailey dance school then studied acting
at the acting studio lorraine headed to
the west end of london where she starred
in musicals like miss saigon fame and
rent but she later returned to the
states to pursue further creative
endeavors at the same time luna was
becoming a recognizable face to
audiences on tv shows such as new york
undercover oz ugly betty and dexter the
two have a single shared credit to their
names the 2002 hitman episode of law and
order but never actually share the
screen during its run time that doesn't
mean the two don't spend time together
when they're off camera however luna
consistently shares photos of the pair
together on her instagram especially on
hashtag twin tuesday
being identical was particularly rough
going on the lawrence brothers who both
decided to become actors at the same
time matthew said to entertainment
weekly if you have to pick a business
not to go into with an identical twin
this is it we didn't talk for a long
time
best known for cleaning teeth as david
silver's dad mel on beverly hills 90210
matthew was born four minutes later than
his twin elder brother mitchell shared
his twins opinions on the entertainment
business saying at times i hate the fact
that matthew's here we have moments of
closeness and a lot of times of conflict
the two were able to get past their
differences and collaborated several
times including for a pair of cop rock
episodes and an appearance on the
commish on saturday night live matthew
was a featured player in season six
while mitchell held various roles
eventually becoming an associate
director in the memorable outer limits
episode in another life mitchell played
a man trapped in an alternate reality
surrounded by many different versions of
himself which were played by both he and
matthew when mitchell decided it was
time to leave the soap opera santa
barbara and move on to reasonable doubts
matthew was there to take his place the
two have since moved away from hollywood
and into the world of golf podcasting
matthew hosts the backspin golf radio
show and podcast for espn while mitchell
is the co-host and co-producer of
talking golf getaways with mitch and
darren
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]